[Music]
let's look at Lebanon we had been
reporting that the president was going
to begin consulting political parties to
find a new prime minister but now
hearing that that has been postponed
we've got zina Hooda in Beirut to take
us through the latest zina yes the
constitutional process to appoint a
prime minister and form a new government
was supposed to begin now the
president's Palace issued a statement
saying that those parliamentary
consultations have been postponed until
Thursday in that statement it mentions
that the caretaker Prime Minister
saddle' Hariri the man who was believed
to be to be nominated by the end of
today asked for this moment in order to
allow for more consultations and
negotiations among the different
political factions Lebanon's political
parties are not in agreement there's a
deep divide yes like I mentioned saddle
Hariri is the likely candidate to return
as Prime Minister he received the
support of the sunday religious
establishment in this country there's a
sectarian based system of government the
post of Prime Minister is reserved for a
Sunday Muslim but he doesn't have enough
support to push ahead with his own
government in Parliament he's gonna need
65 votes in order to get the vote of
confidence in Parliament what side of
Hariri wants is to head a government of
independent technocrats in order to
steer Lebanon out of this economic
crisis but his political rivals mainly
the Iranian backed Hezbollah as well as
the president Michele out they believe
that the next government should have
representatives of the different
political parties so the political
forces are not in agreement on how the
makeup of the next cabinet should be
it's hard bargaining really because if
anyone is to make any concession it
means weakening their political power so
the constitutional process now postponed
many were hoping that a government would
be formed in order to enact much-needed
reforms to receive international aid the
economy is in dire straits people are
losing their jobs companies are closing
local currencies losing value so now
further negotiations expected in the
coming days and in the pressure from the
street continues doesn't designer take
us through what happened on Sunday night
two nights of violence in downtown
Beirut that's the center of the capital
the epicenter of the protest movement
security forces clashing with unarmed
protesters two consecutive nights tear
gas was used rubber bullets water Callan
cannons dozens of protesters were
injured and according to the interior
ministry security forces as well were
injured both sides accusing each other
of instigating the violence people on
the street believe that those in power
the governing elite they have taken the
decision to use the Armed Forces to
crush what what has been really a
peaceful protest movement against those
in power so they believe in what has
believed what we have been seen in the
past few days is excessive use of force
by the Armed Forces against against the
people
[Music]
a second night of violence in central
Beirut tear gas was again used by
security forces to disperse protesters
who were outside Parliament square they
had gathered here in a show of defiance
a day earlier Parliament police used
what Amnesty International described as
excessive force against an
overwhelmingly peaceful protest many now
fear state intimidation against the
leaderless protest movement is growing I
don't think it's possible for people to
see the the way that their the
aggression and the way that they treated
protesters yesterday and to kind of turn
a blind eye even if they were afraid it
seems like they understand that unity
and numbers are really what can create
momentum and that can keep us going Dana
was among the dozens of protesters
beaten up by security forces during
Saturday night's confrontations the
worst since the uprising began in
mid-october both sides accused each
other of instigating the violence there
are fears this could be the beginning of
a new phase what has largely been a
peaceful opposition movement
there seems to be a decision by those in
power for the army and security forces
to confront the protesters this is
dangerous from the start of the uprising
the army took a decision not to be harsh
with the protesters but the situation
has changed in the past few days
government among themselves over the
makeup of the next government the lack
of government makes it difficult to pull
Lebanon out of its worst economic crisis
in decades which is why the protests
began we're not going for weapons we
only need our needs we're asking for our
needs for hospitality for our Hospital
for our medication to eat to have job
all people here are with are jobless all
people and who are working they are
having half their salaries this is
another life their calls for change are
not being heard politicians seem to be
sending a message that they are ready to
use whatever means necessary including
force to protect their power to maintain
stability you're going to need political
agreement a political deal among the
different factions and you're going to
need a government in order to revive the
economy the international community
making it very clear we are not going to
bail out Lebanon this time if the next
government does not meet the aspirations
of the people thank you for all of that
that's zina further reporting from
Beirut